>>> TONIGHT THE WHITHOUSE
ANNOUNCING PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
RST LADY JILL BIDEN ARE
ATTENDING THE QUEEN'S FUNERAL.
BIDEN IS NOT INVITED TO BRING A
DELEGATION WITH HIM WHICH IS A
BREAK FROM OTHER STATE FUNERALS
FOR WORLD LEADERS.
THIS AS WE ARE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE QUEEN'S, QUOTE, BEST
FRIENDS THE TWO CORGIES ALWAYS
BY HER SIDE.
TOM FOREMAN IS OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: AS MUCH AS HER
ROYAL GUARD, ROYAL FAMILY, AND
ROYAL CROWN, THE QUEEN'S
WOBBLING ENTOURAGE OF WELSH
CORGIES WERE A SYMBOL KNOWN
AROUND THE WORLD, WITH THE RUN
OF THE PALACE AND A PLACE IN HER
HEART.
>> THE CORGIES WERE A BIG DEAL.
>> Reporter: WRITING EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT THE ROYAL FAMILY, DOGS AND
ALL.
>> THEY WERE EXTREMELY GOOD
COMPANY FOR HER.
IN GOOD TIMES AND BAD.
AND I THINK THEY MADE HER LAUGH.
>> Reporter: FROM HER YOUTH THE
QUEEN LOVED ANIMALS, HORSES,
HUNTING DOGS, BUT THE CORGIES
WERE SPECIAL.
HER FIRST, SUSAN, WENT ON THE
QUEEN'S HONEYMOON THEN BECAME
MATRIARCH TO A LONG LINE OF
PAMPERED POOCHES FED FROM SILVER
BOWLS, WALKED INCESSANTLY, AND
PLAYING A PECULIAR DIPLOMATIC
ROLE WHEN THE QUEEN MET OTHERS.
>> DIANA SAID THEY WERE LIKE A
LITTLE MOVING CARPET THAT
PRECEDED HER INTO A ROOM.
AND WHENEVER THE CONVERSATION
LAGGED IN ANY WAY, THE CORGIES O
COULD ALWAYS BE COUNTED ON TO
SUPPLY SOME POINT OF
CONVERSATION.
>> Reporter: THE DOGS WERE NOT
ALWAYS SO AGREEABLE.
THE FIRST MINISTER OF SCOTLAND
RECALLED A DINNER WITH THE QUEEN
WHEN THE LIGHTS BEGAN TO FAIL.
>> MY HUSBAND SUDDENLY LIT UP
AND DARTED ACROSS THE ROOM.
PETER HAD SPOTTED THE CAUSE OF
THE FLICKERING LIGHT.
>> Reporter: ONE OF HER
MAJESTY'S CORGIES WAS CHEWING
THROUGH THE CORD.
>> THEY NEVER BIT THE QUEEN, BUT
THEY DID BITE SOME OF HER STAFF.
>> Reporter: THE QUEEN WAS KNOWN
TO HAVE AS MANY AS SIX AT A TIME
AND WHEN SHE CROSS BRED THEM
WITH DAX UNDS SHE WAS CREDITED
WITH CREATING THE DORGIE.
AT THE END THE DOGS IN HER
COMPANY DWINDLED TO JUST A FEW
AND THE LAST ARE DESTINED TO
LIVE WITH THE DUKE AND DUCHESS
OF YORK AND PERHAPS AS THIS
COMIC SUGGESTS LIKE SO MANY
PEOPLE THEY WILL MISS THE LADY
AT THE OTHER END OF THE LEASH.
SOME PEOPLE CLOSER TO THE ROYAL
FAMILY HAVE SAID MAYBE THE
REASON SHE LIKED HER CORGIES SO
MUCH IS BECAUSE SHE COULD GO FOR
WALKS WITH THEM, TALK ABOUT HER
PROBLEMS, AND THEY DIDN'T TALK
BACK.
IN FACT, THEY DIDN'T KNOW OR
CARE THAT SHE WAS THE QUEEN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY COULDN'T LEAK.